26 year old all-star lucas giolito yeah
the right-hander six foot six 245
basically a two pitch pitcher fastball
curveball occasional best pitch is the
change up cesar hernandez switch hitter
manning left-handed he's hitting the air
to the left hit pretty well eloija is
now trying to go toward the line we'll
reach up and make the catch running for
a moment i thought he may have a little
issue with the sun the shadows are out
there and the sun is directly shining in
left here is frankie lindor the indian
switch heading short stop batting
left-handed ground ball to first base
first chance therefore he has money
grandall hill field wave off the help
tag the bag and one two three go the
indians here in the top of the first
inning well shane bieber will face the
white sox for the first time in 2020
lifetime he's two and two with a 308 era
and six career starts shane bieber right
now without question he's been the best
pitcher in major league baseball laori
garcia leading off tonight
on the appeal they ring him up yeah why
not for st bieber starting his night
with a strikeout moncada hitting 305
three homers six rbis and it swung on
and missed another curveball and another
strikeout so bieber's first two
strikeouts coming
on curveballs the d.a jose abreu will
lead off against shane bieber that's a
high fly ball into left field backing up
now is freeman he'll turn he'll look and
this one is gone jose and brave on the
cleanup spot puts the white sox on the
board first it's one nothing just the
third run allowed all year by shane
bieber all three of them by the way have
come on solo homers well you don't get
many cracks at geolito you have a chance
to have a big inning you better
capitalize top of the order and cesar
hernandez the batter a swing and a long
drive to deep right center robert on the
run it's over his head freeman is going
to score and the indians are back to
even at 1-1
and they have scored their first run in
over two years against lucas giolito and
jose ramirez will step to the plate
swings and rips one to right field it's
a base hit leone will score the indians
take a 2-1 lead and the indians have had
back-to-back rbi hits
lucas has really had to work hard to
keep this a one-run game he's walked
five tonight that's his highest walk
total in a game since a five walk outing
against the crosstown cubs in july of
last season and now it's a guy who's
drawn two of them against him and that's
carlos santana he's swinging and he
lines it to the right side of the
infield to wrap things up they finally
make him put it in play jimenez with
three homers and eight runs driven in on
the season breaking ball swung on him
missed strength three ball dropped and
picked up by leon who throws to first to
complete the strikeout
has retired on strikeout number four for
shane bieber here is nomar mazzara
walked his first time he gets one
swinging on mazzara for his fifth of the
ball game that ball almost hit his back
catcher james mccann will open up the
white sox sixth inning shane bieber has
struck out five walked one and that's a
high fly ball into deep left field
freeman won't even make an attempt at
that one it's way out of here james
mccann
has tied the game with one swing his
homer to left makes it a 2-2 game here
in the sixth very intelligent hitting by
mccann
second walk issued today by bieber and
that'll bring up guys monty grandahl 3-2
pitch into the air to right center field
that's going to be a gapper going all
the way to the wall moncada turning
third he's going to score and grand all
will get to second with an rbi double
three two white sox here in the sixth
this is a huge huge inning for giolito
really want to reward your hitters for
battling against bieber
the o2 pitch swing and a miss strike
three seven strikeouts for lucas giolito
will bring up bradley zimmer swinging a
miss strike three got him lucas giolito
meanwhile is in a groove with
back-to-back strikeouts to start the
seventh inning strike recall
and the inning is over lucas giolito
strikes out the side he's puffed so the
indians have the tying run aboard
franmio reyes the indians hitter swung
on line shot toward the gap and left
center to base hit it'll go all the way
to the wall santana around third will
try to score there will be no throw
and a huge gain tying base hit has tied
this game at three runners at first and
second two down for the guy you really
want up there
jose ramirez ground ball to second base
mendic down to a need of field throw to
first is gonna be in time and damage
averted two dangerous men are retired
and now nomar mazara strike three goal
he crossed them up with a fastball and
no chance to pull the trigger for mazara
runners at the corners and the indians
with a chance to break this 3-3 tie and
a bunt down the first baseline coming
home ramirez beats the throw with a head
first slide and the indians take the
lead with a little small ball and lead
it four to three tribe up four to three
runners at the corners mike freeman they
hit her swings and it's a ground ball
back up the middle into center that's a
huge rbi hit and they lead this ball
game white sox with a man at third and
one out here in the bottom of the
10-foot and mccann hits that in the air
to straight away center now coming in
and having to play it on a bounce is
zimmer it gets by him a run's gonna
score it's now a 5-4 game there's a lot
of rain i i can't believe we're still
playing and you should see the amount of
water on the infield and now they're
finally calling for the tarp so after a
44 minute delay garcia pops out it's
going to be up to johann moncada check
swinging a foul tip hung onto by leone
ball game that'll go as a strikeout and
oliver perez gets the save